and all my friends are
dead and I failed them and I didn't get
down in
time because that's what you
think now logically I was off duty I did
the best I could to get there as fast as
I could but in my
mind the guys that would have died for
me in a second they died without me
being there next to him and it bothered
me for a long time it's not that I want
to be dead but I felt like I failed
him my childhood one of my childhood
crew one of my best buddies right here
John
Sharp he was on
duty all the guy did was work because he
had two babies at home and he wanted to
keep his wife home do it the way our
parents did it mom stays home dad goes
to
work and he raced
in and he
died and I searched for him and all
these other guys Hank Miller Dennis Jr
Al Proby Jimmy Richie's who died over in
Manhattan on the training
assignment just hundreds of other guys
that I I I can't say I knew all the guys
who died right but I knew a lot of them
personally Father
Judge my beautiful Irish
chaplain
loaded me into a CAT scan tube help pick
me up put me into a CAT scan tube in
1983 when I in the end it turned out
that I fractured my cervical
7even it took years for a doctor to
figure it out I couldn't move that night
couldn't move my feet my
arms five six years later I'm caught in
a collapse I go for another CAT scan
x-rays dock goes who what what are you
even doing working on this job on this
truck you fractured your vertebrae years
ago you shouldn't even be able to walk
run around you know you should be
partially
disabled and he was an Irish guy he was
a fire PL doctor and he was a combat
surgeon over in the
gulf and I said doc the only way I can
explain it is in 19993 when I was in a
pretty rough firet truck
accident before I Got Loaded in the cat
Canan to Father Judge put his hands on
me and he said you're going to be okay
don't worry about this God's got it and
he loaded me
in and the doctor doctor looked at me he
was Irish guy Catholic guy he goes yep I
got it I get it that's what happened
move on and Father Judge raced in there
to pray as the chaos of the towers was
going on there's a video of him famous
documentary he's in there and he's
praying he's just praying and praying to
God for everybody to be
okay and he ended up from from the
debris coming down around him he he
actually had a heart attack from you
know dodging this huge piece of
structure and They Carried him out and
later on he was actually hit with more
debris but it ended up they they think
in the end that he he just died of a
heart attack as that debris crushed next
to him and he was he was going out to
give last rights to the people who were
jumping out of the
building and and he died tending to his
flock which was the FDNY he l loved
us and we loved
him and I was down here
for you know we we stayed the first
night right through we couldn't see
anymore we couldn't breathe literally we
just caked with dust and tell tell me
what that morning was
like
morning like I I I try to be forthright
with everyone and say look I got there
after the initial ensuing chaos had
taken place buildings were hit buildings
were burning people were jumping I got
down I saw the second one go down but I
got there to a debris
field and then seven came down and we we
were initially searching for all these
attached buildings in the World Trade
Center complex because they there was
reports of people still trapped in air
and we spent hours and hours until we
could give an all clear for uh those
buildings and then we then just got upon
the pile there was uh couple of Port
Authority of New York and New Jersey
police officers that were still trapped
and in the end they were the only
survivors that were
retrieved after the initial collapses
you know there was a couple people
pulled out within moments or
hours but well into that night they were
the last two live Souls that were taken
out so we worked on that bringing in
equipment bringing out you know buckets
of debris and we just just frantically
you know hundreds of guys trying to get
to these two police
officers and we kept going back and
forth for four or five
days until
finally you know Chief goes look just go
home get home to your families for 12
hours and then get back and you know
just just you gota you got to check in
so my family wasn't really certain of my
fate until
I guess about 12 hours later I was able
to get off a phone
call my mom said that my dad had he was
well retired he we went down in the
Staten Island Ferry they were asking for
any retirees or anybody that could help
they assuming that they were going to
bring in be bringing over hundreds and
hundreds of bodies and they were going
to ship them over on a Staten Island
Ferry and then bring them to more
trucks would never happened
because there was no bodies to pull out
out eventually there was some bodies
that were intact that were found after
hours and days and weeks of
digging but half half of the
2,977 souls that were
lost have never been identified they
were not fully intact you know I think
there was only 200 people that were more
or less intact and that's that's
horrifying you
know but but uh I got home after 4 days
my wife says well I have some good news
and you I was just not in my right state
of mind at all and she she says we're
going to have another baby it's is my
youngest beautiful
daughter and and I was just taken back
and I said oh my God that's great that's
great but you know John John's having a
baby too his wife we just found out this
morning she's pregnant but he's
dead and I didn't know how to verbalize
that without being
harsh and uh John was found on Christmas
Eve and strange enough he was one of the
only Souls found intact and his wife was
so courageous she literally went to
identify him and take his wedding ring
off and uh we buried him on Christmas
Eve I'm sorry New Year's Eve found on
Christmas Eve and it was so cold it was
it was near zero degrees and I remember
I remember how having the honor of
holding the American flag at a service
and and I just would rather have been
dead than to move that flag and it was
so cold and my I ended up with frostbite
in my hands CU I just didn't want to
disrespect my
friend and we had a memorial service
prior was on November 12th and it was
the day the plane crash went down over
in Jamaica Jamaica Bay out in B Harbor
queens and I remember standing in line
at his memorial service it was like a
semi Mass but there was no
body and then we heard the Command Staff
their radio started just just going wild
and it was a there was a plane crash and
they just said look guys we need to keep
some people here for this service I
respect this family we got plenty of
guys heading over there don't just go
racing in you know because there's an
accountability thing if you if you go
running in off duty to events they don't
want you doing that cuz nobody knows
where you're going nobody's looking for
you if you don't resp bond in as a unit
as as as a squad or you know
so and I just remember standing there
going what the hell's going on a plane
crash you
know and there was a lot of allegations
suspection that it was terrorism and
there's still some people that firmly
believe it was because tail assemblies
and wings don't just Shear off of
aircraft but you know I I don't want to
go there because you'll get hate mail
but I just still don't believe believe
that that was a random a random
accident and uh yeah we brought John
home and sent them home to God on New
Year's Eve and and then it was just
months and months and months of digging
and they
finally uh I think it was May 30th 2002
where they actually ceremonially closed
down the site it was cleaned
out and uh still couldn't identify half
the people that were found there and to
this day It's haunting to those families
like some some folks believe it or not
in the last two or three years have been
identified because they've I guess
improved the DNA recognition
technology but my my lieutenant
Dennis he's never had closure for his
his beautiful son and uh as a father
that that kills
me but it was it was a hard hor it was a
horrible place it was it was it was like
a war movie um when we were digging and
and within within I don't know an hour
there was fighter jets just screaming
over and you'd see them go mile out and
just scream into a turn Bank into a 40
50 degree turn and come screaming back
and and I looked at some of my guys and
like Cruis is we at War cuz you know we
still didn't really know what happened
we knew there was an attack OB obiously
we we we we we were waiting for it
because in in '90s in the late '90s
there was a a fdmi training manual with
a picture of a sketch of the twin towers
and it had a Target on one of the towers
and it said not a matter of if but a
matter of when be ready be
trained and I'm just like whoa they did
they notice was coming or did you
know so we the guy guys who were there
in '93 and and uh we kind of always had
that in the back of our mind that
they're not going to give this up
they're going to come they're going to
come get us
so that morning on until we really were
were told otherwise we we thought we
were at War CU there was still rumors
going around that you know there was
other aircraft in the air and they were
they were trying to hit you know the
White House and they wanted to
hit uh you know other other monuments
there was you know they were going to
hit the stock exchange they were going
to hit you know
symbolically punch Us in the face these
terrorists and
uh I just
remember later on into that night I I
broke off to a uh a little area further
away from the whole Crush of guys
because nobody was really searching over
here and I'm like you know maybe we just
need to like split up our resources and
so I was with this older fireman from my
dad's old truck 172 and uh looking
around and he stops
me he goes yo bro what what do you he
and at the time there was just this sand
that was just kind of it almost looked
like a dune that was falling away it was
just gray pulverized sand and it was
just cascading down and you could hear
it like a and then you could hear like
this hissing that was just cons
consistent like a gas leak and then
maybe a water leak and I said I said
well I hear some sort of leak and I hear
the sand he goes no no no no what else
do you
hear and I went nothing and he pointed
at a lady's pocketbook and a lady's shoe
and a wallet they were just kind of
straggled in in that
pile and he goes where's the people
and and it was almost like a mind game
and I said bro I I don't know where are
they he goes
exactly they're no longer bro he goes
look at the disintegration of this
massive structure that's the World Trade
Center looks like a freaking Sand Dune
in the desert and someone just died it
everybody's dead nobody's coming out of
here we're wasting our time and he
didn't mean that we were going to give
up and not search obviously but he he
knew he just knew I guess he had you
know 30 years of experience and whatever
like they were all
gone and and they were you know for for
the first five days we we clung to hopes
that there was guys maybe or people
trapped in you know a crass or or you
know the the structure kind of caved
into itself but left an opening and left
an area and there was enough air and uh
on our self self-contained breathing
apparatus which is our air tanks in The
Mask there's a there's a an alarm a
motion alarm called a pass alarm so if
you stop moving for 30 seconds it just
cycles and makes this loud piercing
noise so so your fellow Rescuers come
find you it means you're down right and
for a few days till the batteries died
we heard those passing alarms in in the
pile underneath because the guy who was
wearing it who is now dead well his pass
along was doing its job it was saying
I'm here come get me but we couldn't
because they were underneath 40 or 50
feet of debris and until we could get
cranes and you know all of the trades
guys came in the iron workers and heavy
duty construction guys and until until
we could start really moving stuff and
then getting into these
areas and by the time we were able to do
that it was too late they were I don't
think think any of them
survived the initial Onslaught because
you know I'm not a Science Guy of a
little bit of night college but
uh the forces and physics
involved no one could survive that you
know it it disintegrated structural
members how how is a human being of you
know mostly water and flesh how are they
going to survive
that and and that was the outcome it was
just uh it was just sad cuz there was
thousands of people waiting for news of
their loved ones and some sort of they
were they were still clinging to the
hopes that we could find them and and
that they were somehow miraculously
alive and and that didn't
happen how many friends did you did you
lose like from the fire you
know they call it the Brotherhood and
you know now we have female firefighters
to
sisters so within the Brotherhood it
doesn't matter where a guy works or you
know he's your brother and then there's
that just those levels of friendship
right guys from your own crew and guys
from a crew you used to work with guys
you knew from training school guys you
just knew from growing up in the
neighborhood you know like John and I
grew up together played football
together baseball together and then we
he happened to be the next we were a
single ladder company they were a single
engine company at the time
now they've com they've combined the two
into the same building but back then
John and I they were sister companies so
we were one block one Avenue away we'd
respond in on every call together so as
far as a friend that close joh almost as
close as it got but then there was other
guys that I mean just dozens and dozens
that I a lieutenant who I drove for 10
shifts that was filling in on a vacation
coverage where we we were you know there
was just so many interconnecting
relationships guys you knew well guys
you didn't know so well but you really
enjoyed the couple times you work with
them
uh I knew so many but worse than that I
know so many now that are dying of
cancer um and like just an unending
amount of guys that are dying of cancer
it's actually scary and you picked up
leukemia yeah I
um one of my best buddies uh my buddy
Bobby and I we probably in 0203 we
started noticing that guys were starting
to get sick they but it was it wasn't it
wasn't so severe there was limited
cancer so so they chalked it off to just
cancer happens in the fire service but
then all of a sudden there was this
young firefighter John
mcnamer came down with a vicious colon
cancer and he was just gone had a
newborn baby and then we realized
there's a problem cuz now guys started
coming hey you hear this guy's got
cancer Mark's got cancer Bobby's got
cancer Nils got cancer and my friend
Bobby said wow it's like a mine field
when when are we going to step on our
mine I said I hope never this from
breathing all the debris breathing all
toxic toxic debris and I was there the
day that our government sent EPA rep to
tell us everything's great the air is
clean it wasn't so I wasn't feeling good
starting in about 2007 2008 I just I was
just a wreck I just did not feel
myself my weight would go up and down I
I I would I'd be so cold then all of a
sudden I couldn't cool down I just
really weird things and I kept going to
the doctor and my doctor on the outside
actually worked for the fire department
as well so um early on we had issues a
lot of guys were having a hard time and
I went to talk to a counselor myself I'm
not embarrassed to say it I
was I was having a hard time processing
the survivor's guilt and why is my my
good bu dead and I'm not you know why
why needed some answers so I willingly
went talked to a counselor and you know
it helped a bit but the minute you talk
to a counselor they put something on
your medical folder like a Scarlet
Letter like uhoh this guy went to a
counselor
and then
unfortunately some of the guys started
abusing alcohol to ease the pain of
everything they've been through was
still going through
so the command I think was chalking off
a lot of ailments to alcoholism and
PTSD so in 2011 I went for a routine
fire department medical with blood work
and 3 days later when the results came
back they pulled me off of for Duty they
relieved me from Duty saying that my
Bloods had crashed it was a Friday and
they're like s just come in on Monday
don't overthink it I'm like you're
telling me I can't even ride the truck
that I could my platelets were gone
which is your
cladder you're telling me that I can't
even ride the fire truck but don't worry
about it uh that's kind of
conflicting so I I took it upon myself
to ask a couple of medical people in my
family I said hey here's my blood work
you know
what the
hell and uh my one brother-in-law who I
love is one of my buddies we grew up
together and uh he we call me angel of
death he's a nurse manager and he
went like that no good and I'm like what
the hell you mean he says I I don't like
it it doesn't look good so they the
doctor strung me out oh you're
overthinking this I said I think this is
cancer this this this is appearing as
cancer to everybody I talk to and the
doctor arrogantly enough said oh you're
another Web MD right you're another
internet doctor and you know it I said
no I'm not I'm not going to Discount
your education and your expertise but
I'm telling you I feel like I've been
dying the last couple
years
well 3 weeks after they pulled me from
the truck and still hadn't told me what
was wrong I was waiting at the fire
department
doctor I went for an appointment to find
out what the hell is wrong and the
doctor didn't go up she left she was
gone for the
day and I was fading and I I told the
charge Doctor Who was there you know the
triage nurse intercepted me and and he
he just took me to the side and he goes
look I just want to be blunt you're not
a drugs guy or or heavy Boozer are
you and I looked at the nurse and he was
there for years this guy Jimmy a great
guy and I started tearing up and now I
had a packet going I had a couple weeks
of tests and this and this and this and
I said Jimmy I think I'm dying I don't
know what else to say he looked at it he
goes all right all right he takes my
blood pressure it's 240 over 140 now for
a uh fat Irish Danish
guy I've always had great blood pressure
very lucky so he takes it again he goes
who and my spleen was out like a
football it looked like a damn Super
Bowl fraking game ball
and
uh he takes it again and then he goes oh
shoot and he goes hold on a minute and
he calls in the charge doctor and the
doctor takes it and now I was completely
red I looked like a
tomato and uh I probably looked almost
like a tomato cuz I still get that flush
stuff but doctor palpated my spleen and
he looked at my paperwork and he went
took the blood pressure one more time
and it was still going up and he looked
at Jimmy he said I think think he's
going to rupture his spleen is about to
go code him call call Ms Advance life
support don't send like there's two
levels of ambulance you know basic life
support EMTs higher levels
paramedics send send Medics we need to
get them out of here
now well my doctor comes rolling in
because they paged their back and she's
pissed off because we disrupted her
launch so she gets into a disagreement
with the responding
paramedic who takes a look at the jacket
I now have of tests and whatever and
just says to anybody who cared why isn't
this guy in the
hospital
and this doctor he he he was questioning
her and she was
pissed and so he said look uh I think
this man
quite possibly has a blood blood cancer
when you look at what's happening in the
spleen and you look at the crash of the
platelets and she just
went this is just another case of
alcohol abuse because you know the
spleen is huge and and the blood
pressure is probably
PTSD so he went oh
really have a nice day raced me over to
meadus which is a trauma center and I
got in the ambulance with this guy A guy
ran within the Street we used to cut
people out of a car wreck underneath the
elevated Highway hand them off to this
guy very tall guy African-American dude
I call him doc cuz when I was in the
Army I was a medic and they call you doc
if you're a medic so he remembered me
and I said doc what the f is going on
and he looked at me he goes listen man I
hate to do this but you're really sick
but don't worry about it we're not going
to send you home without finding out
what's going on so so fast forward they
get me in there doctor explains to me he
goes look we need to drill into your
head take bone marrow scan it look at it
figure out what's going on I said well
what are you why you doing that he says
well we think you have blood cancer I
said I could have told you a month ago
but okay so a few days later REM mind
you my doctor never shows up right she
pissed CU some a question
and
3 Days Later a team of doctors walks in
and I'm like whoa either they're all
looking to make a bill here or I'm dying
because usually you see one doctor two
doctors there was six so they said look
we give you the good news or give you
the bad news I said give me the bad news
first you have something called hary
cell leukemia you've had it for a couple
years it's a good thing you got in here
you were a couple days away from dying
you your your your playlist you gone you
were done the good news is we've
developed the protocol that we've had
success getting people into remission
it's technically by the books Never
curable but long-term remissions for we
don't know how long I said okay what how
are we going to get to remission and the
guy goes well you're not going to enjoy
this but you're going to get 2 and 1/2
years worth of chemo in 7 days this bags
this big that just never stops
and it's vicious it's CTIC you're going
to feel like you're burning to death
from the inside out but that's the chemo
doing its job if it works you're in
remission I said what if it doesn't work
he said you're dead just like that okay
fair
enough so I tried to give my family
little bits and pieces of what was
really going on cuz I didn't want to
horrify
them my wife had just lost her mom and
you know it was just a bad
time and uh so my nurse was this guy
Mike nunz he was incredible incredible
caregiver and I had these various other
ladies that also but Mike was like my
main nurse and he told me he says once
we hooked they they had to actually fly
in the treatment from Cleveland Clinic
because it's such a rare cancer and it's
such a rare medicine that they they just
don't stock it so they had to fly it in
you know first time I got my only jet
was my camo on the jet so uh felt like
the 1centers you know so um Mike told me
he says once I Infuse this he he goes I
have to wear a hazmat suit he says if it
gets Airborne it'll burn anything in its
path but once it's in it's okay so when
he went to First do the IV it spilled
and it literally melted the tube and I
started pound Mike you're not putting
this crap in my body what the freak you
know he I'm sorry he goes I got to start
it over and I said no you're not doing
it I'd take a pass I'm good and he goes
NOS listen to me he goes those three
beautiful kids that you know my kids
were young at the
time if you really want to see them
again you got you got to do this you're
you're going to die and I said all right
all right Mike and I you know I was
crying I said okay let's let's go let me
let me man up let's go and uh he hit me
now I've never done drugs a couple of my
friends who have said you know once you
infuse yourself with something you feel
that warm feeling or whatever well this
crap it was a burning feeling it was
like holy but it was strange cuz my skin
wasn't hot but I felt like I had a
boiling cup of water just flowing
through my body and that and Mike said
he goes that's that's the thing starting
its job he says unfortunately you're
going to have that for about seven or
eight
days and I said Mike you've been you
done this with people he says no you're
the first one this is such a rare cancer
he goes but what what I was told by the
doctors is that the first two nights are
critical he said because this cancer is
usually found in elderly men who work in
refineries with diesel and uh
kerosene I think it's like from Benzene
so uh the
chemical he said uh most of our patients
are elderly and a lot of times in the
first or second night their heart or
their liver or their kidneys will give
out and they'll die so he goes and I
asked him to be straight up with me from
the beginning and he was and uh he goes
so if you make it through these first
couple nights I think you're in a good
spot bro all right Mike that first night
was a wild one there was this wicked
wicked
thunderstorm and it was one of the
heaviest rainfalls in New York City
history I think it was like 14 inches in
some spots roads were flooded it was
crazy non-stop lightning for hours but
in my mind my mind I was imagining it
because once that chemo started coursing
through me I was losing my mind I
couldn't hear I couldn't see at times it
was it was
vicious and some patients I've talked to
in chat rooms whatever said that they
did drugs in the 60s and that this
protocol of chemo was a Wilder ride than
acid in the 60s and I'm like whoa okay
cuz I agree it was
wild pushing on through the storm I'm
laying there and and I'm trying to fall
asleep it been days now that I was in
there still hadn't seen my doctor and I
can't sleep and my body is just being
ravaged and it it was it was the worst
feeling in the world you know I've been
caught in fires a couple times you know
bad situation started to burn and and
this was this was
worse and all of a sudden I start I'm
trying to sleep and I start seeing a
flash a face of someone I loved who
passed
but they'd come and then they would fade
and they were all
smiling and this went on for a little
while it was like you know cuz I've lost
a lot of people unfortunately and I
started getting like nervous I'm like
why why am I seeing them I'm like
there's my grandma there my grandpa
there's my Irish grandmother I never met
my mom's dad you know picture of him it
was weird it was just and and all of a
sudden as it's going it's going and and
I see my buddy Jackie who I worked with
in Manhattan but Jackie is alive but all
these other people have passed and then
the last person is my my beautiful Irish
mother-in-law who I adored she was just
such a sweet lady went to church every
day she used to call me her boyfriend
because we just got each other we I like
to talk you know and she did too and all
of a sudden there's my mother-in-law she
passed six months earlier and she's kind
of shrouded and and and like white she
just looked beautiful and and she's
smiling and and she had this cute little
laugh and she's giggling and and we
called her Nan and I'm trying to reach
for her I'm like Nan
Nan I want to go take me with you you
look so happy and she says I am happy my
boyfriend but no he's not ready yet you
go back you go back to any and the kids
and no I'll See You Someday but not now
and she's she's receeding away and I'm
like no no no she's just giggling not
yet no my boyfriend and she just
feeds and I wake up and I'm I mean I'm
just in a fever pitch and my nurse who
was very religious she she was from the
islands and she says my fireman what
what is going on and her name is Al
graia and I explain to her I said you
know she said okay she says they're
telling you it's good you you you just
keep
fighting so when they told one of the
doctors who was tending to my case the
next day she was
she was an atheist and we had a previous
conversation about faith and whatever
and uh I was praying at one point I said
hey Doc you want to pray with me and she
said no I'd rather not and I you know so
I being the study of people I needed to
know why and she said well my my dad was
a heavy-handed Muslim and I I think all
that stuff's bull crap and I went okay
no problem so now when they told her
what happened and I was having these
visions and I was you know whatever
seeing my mother-in-law in
heaven
she sent oh but this is this is why she
she made a shrink come talk to me so the
second to last person I saw was Jack my
buddy from the firehouse I filled in
down South Street Cort Ladder 15 they
lost 14 guys that's where Fitzroy hannes
got thrown off the
truck and I'm like why the hell did I
see Jack like I I could figure out like
everybody I saw was past they love them
they let me know they're
okay why
Jack so my friend Jean comes in that
morning just prior to this doctor and
he's a big dude and he doesn't show his
emotions and he's crying I'm like Gino I
go am I dying man am I dying he goes no
no man no no it's not you it's not you
don't worry about it and I said well why
are you crying I'm not crying I said you
freaking
crying and he goes no no I'm not I'm not
talking about it and I looked at him I
says it's Jack isn't it and he goes who
the told you who he's Furious I
said I told him not to tell you I
thought I said tell me what and he just
he goes nothing no I said Jackie's dead
and he goes how do you know how I said
because at 5:00 this morning during my
chemo Haze or whatever they want to call
it this and that I said and I told them
I saw everybody I saw that guy that guy
and my mother
I saw Jack and he looked at me he goes
Jack died at 5:00 this
morning he's killed on a motorcycle
accident and he was
Upstate and he crashed and he landed in
a ditch and he was there dying and he
threw his helmet up on the
road and the helmet bounced the front of
a
car and they
stopped and they heard Jack yelling and
he was down there and his leg was cut
off so they flew a helicopter in with
the state police and the fire volunteer
firemen were there and Jack beat a
Jack he looks up at the flight medic he
goes what the took you so long
bro and he was
gone and some somehow in some strange
way I knew I don't know
how no one told me I had no cell phone I
couldn't hear anything I could barely
see anything with the
chemo so now my atheist doctor hears all
this story my whole diet tribe and she
thinks I lost my mind so she
sends a
shrink a couple hours later in walks
this
man and in Brooklyn where we were we ran
into borrow Park and there's a has the
community so he look just like a rabbi
from the community and comes walking in
I say Hey sir are you I say Rabbi he
goes yes yes but I'm also a doctor I
said oh I said you here to you know talk
religion you know I thought maybe they
sent him as a Chaplain he says no I'm
actually here for a different reason uh
I need to know what's going on with you
I says oh doc I got cancer I you know
they zapping the out of me would
you see these bags of juice here he goes
well doctor says you might be
hallucinated or whatever tell me tell me
what happened
so I go on the whole story like I just
told
you and he looks at me and he starts to
giggle and he says my friend I believe
you he
said he
goes our religions he goes it's sort of
like working for a corporation he goes
we all work for this big big Corporation
of God and he goes but we're in
different departments you're Catholic
I'm Jewish and then he
goes your loved ones are letting you
know that it's okay and you need to
fight and you need and I told him about
Jack and he went your friend's
okay
so and he's just like that was it so I
says doc so I am losing my mind a little
bit with this stuff he goes oh yeah he
goes it's it's going to he goes Cho's
going to kill everything but he goes
it's going to kill what they need to
kill he says you're going to have a
little while to go before everything's
back to normal physically and
mentally I said but I'm okay he goes
yeah
so he goes so what do you want to talk
about now I said what do you mean he
goes pay me for an hour that only took
30 minutes he goes you want to watch the
Yankees so I sat there with the rabbi
watching the Yankee game you know so he
gave me the old you're good and I I
still to this day I I can't explain that
experience
why
how
but I've lived in this body for 55 years
and I know it you know um
as my wife says there's a whole lot
going on up in this and there is but I
know what I saw and the conversation
with my mother-in-law cuz it was just
like we were still there talking away
before she
died
so on my 14th
day of my 25 days in the cancer
W my doctor showed up
finally but she got to be ordered to
show up by the fire commissioner because
I don't know why she was ducking me
dodging me covering the tracks I I don't
know but arrogantly enough walks in and
says to me had no idea what was
wrong so what is it that's wrong with
you today
lieutenant and I went what like now I
I'm gone I mean I lost 50 lounds and my
I mean it was
bad I I was praying to die it was bad
and she I said and I'm like nah I can't
be hearing this lady right I said pardon
me ma'am what did you say I said I I I
can't hear really well she said so what
is she crosses her leg and she just so
what is it that's wrong with you today
Lieutenant with that inflection of
arrogance and there's six of my guys
that are standing around and they saw my
reaction it was it was from the soul it
was visceral it was like I want I oh
crush this lady like I'm in a football
game I
said what did you say I said did you
even have the courtesy and the respect
to look and I unleash some explo you
know as a faithful man I curse a lot I'm
sorry to anybody who's offended but I do
it gets gets things out I said did you
even have the eff and courtesy to look
in my folder to see what's going on do
you know where I am right I leaned up on
my my my arm was Ted this huge Tower of
IV I said do you even know what water
I'm in here do you know where I am oh no
I said I'm in the cancer I'm not
getting out of here for a month and she
goes I said I have the rarest form of
leukemia I've had it for years I was
couple days away from death and you told
me I was a drunk in a nut job and I
go and I'm dying and she's like I'm
sorry to hear that and I went so am I
ma'am now get the F out of my room
you're effing fired off my case and
she's like excuse me like you don't talk
to fire department donath's that way I
said ma'am please I can barely hear you
from this crap they're putting through
me I can barely see you I don't want to
do something I'm going to regret and
lose my career I said get the out
of my
room and the arrogance and the
indifference that just oozed from this
lady like I did even matter and I'm
going I gave 22 years of my life to this
department I was on the honor guard the
ceremony team you know for burying all
the the guys who passed and I go I I've
given 100% of my soul to this city in
this department and this is how you
treat
me so they assigned me another
department doctor and I never well I saw
her one more time at a funeral 6 months
ago looked right at her another guy he
died got a lung transplant from 911
didn't work
she there she is and I just wanted to go
up and say why did you do that she saw
me turned around couple Fire Marshals
approached me and they said you know
you're not going to confront the doctor
I said why should I they knew what was
going on I said nah that's not how I
roll bro I was raised better than that I
said you tell that lady she's disgusting
and I walked
away and you know what it's okay I'm
past it I wasn't for a long
time but I spent my life caring about
people and helping people my the
majority of my adult life was just
helping people and never once did I do
half CPR on somebody or half put their
fire out or half cut them out of a
wrecked vehicle I did my job wasn't the
best at it but I tried my best and I
just was like Wow but the doctors I I
ended up with you know I had gone down
waiting for that doctor that day
literally passed out it's the best thing
that could have ever happened because
they saved my life because if I kept
waiting for her to determine what was
wrong I wouldn't have made it I had they
said maybe 48 72 hours that was it that
was it I was checking
out and it took a really long
time to get past I I had a lot of my
anger I really did because I was retired
off the department I got into remission
officially Thanksgiving the day after
Thanksgiving of of 11 and by January of
12 I was out the door they retired me
out on medical that's it you you know
you have 20 years you have cancer you're
liability you're
out and now I'm I'm one January day I
get a call about 6:00 at night you
congratulations I'm like what you
congratulate me for I don't want to be
retired I want to do 15 more fraking
years and I take my rescue Greyhound out
and she's since crossed the Rainbow
Bridge and a great dog best dog in the
world and I'm out there walking in a
snow storm and um she she would listen
this St I swear to God she uh my wife
and my kids are tired of hearing me so
my dog would listen and it was like she
understood you just look up at you and I
just said Katie what are we going to do
now and I I swear it was like she said
we're just going to have more walks cuz
you're retired and and that was it it
was over my career was gone and my wife
finally sat me down one day she goes
look I was in a funk it was it was it
was bad I was more sad and depressed
about losing the department about
putting that helmet on that made me feel
like I mattered and I was able to help
other people in that
capacity gone my life's dream my life's
work beyond my family my purpose and and
beyond my friends and family my passion
that's all I had was my friends my
family and the fire department that's
all that mattered to me baseball went
away that was a passion back in the day
that was
it and then I stopped and I said you
know what stop being a victim man you
you you're still alive you know she said
my wife said to me she goes you're alive
you have these children and I remember
in the height of of the came out I
begged God begged please God please my
kids are 14 11 and 9 please let me see
them just get to adulthood let me help
them there let me let me guide them let
me just just even if I have to lay in a
hospital bed or a wheelchair just let me
see them get
there and now that they're there the
huge fear that I have every day and
again it doesn't cause me to not
function but is God gave me what I asked
for that time cuz they're adults now
they're they're finishing up their
educations and they're wonderful human
beings and they work their asses off and
so just they bring so much love goodness
to the
world oh you let me see it so now I want
to be selfish and say hey God let me
hold my grandkids let me go to their
weddings just give
me just some more
time because in this crazy crazy world
they're tired of hear me but
every once in a while they do ask for
some advice and some reason and I try to
give them I just say look this is just
my experience my opinion but it
worked so selfishly enough I'm asking
him
for I oh 10 more 20 more years you look
healthy well I'm fat as my as my buddies
and my old fire companies say I'm the
fattest cancer patient they know which
means they still love me and I love them
scary though there so many of them were
sick and there's so many of them
died now I first got
sick I wasn't in remission yet and I had
to go down to a fire department doctor
and they just had to evaluate how I was
doing the new
doctor and I'm in there and I see my
buddy I've known for years Lar
and Larry was one of those guys you know
we didn't grew up together we didn't
hang out all the time together but
anytime I saw him big hug big greeting I
love the guy big Irish guy be of a man
great fireman and you know in the fire
department culture there's a lot of ball
breaking and Larry worked in rescue 5
which is the heavy rescue company
they're in Staten Island they come over
the bridge to Brooklyn and they cover
25% of Brooklyn All stat Island so
anytime we caught a work in fire in 114
they come cruising over the bridge and
they you know their rescue companies are
there for any craziness or God forbid we
go down they come get us
so good engine and truck companies we
like to tell them screw you we don't
need you you know like it's it's all
that that jocularity you know Macho bull
crap so I loved when I'd see Larry he
drove big Irish guy coming across the
rescue fire he rescue take up go back
over the bridge make sure you pay the
damn toll we don't need you you know and
just big hug now all of a sudden I see
him and he's in the
clinic and he looked like he lost a lot
of weight but he looked great look
great and I said Larry gez you look you
look fantastic what are you
doing goes ah knows uh I'm
sick and uh I got
cancer and and I took his his arm and I
said I'm sorry bro I
said I'm with you I know I got it
too and he told me what he had s the dad
number and it was spreading you know
they were fighting it chemo radiation
and this and
that it gives me a big
hog and he looks me in the eyes I know
his brother Tommy well Tommy was a
police officer my neighbor he says don't
worry brother I'm I'm three quarters
Irish and I'm a quarter Danish he says
we're too big mix the ain't getting
us we're going to beat
it and a year later I'm standing
at his
funeral as they carrying him
in this 290 lb bear of a gentleman is
now 125 lbs
emaciated and those bastards didn't beat
us that day taking down our
buildings but man they're punching the
out of us all these years later but
we still keep getting out still keeps
swinging and now I go home
and I go
God here's Larry you have five kids he's
got grandkids he's the greatest guy in
the world like why and now it's 10 years
later 11 years later and I'm still why
we just
buried you know another buddy of mine
couple months back and then month before
that month before
that I pray every
night my whole
life
I started doing it when my dad was
sick and I have a
chain and I put people that I love in
it and my buddy John the other John the
baseball player who died leukemia when
he was
14 and I remember going to his funeral
and watching his mom and he looked just
like his
mom she's so destroyed his father was
destroyed and every single night since
then I've prayed please let him be in
heaven
and then I added and added and
added and now if I want to mention by
name everybody I cared
about everybody I loved everybody who I
stood their
funeral takes me 45
minutes so now I group them I'll still
mention the first dozen and then I put
groups five my friends my high school
friends the guys who OED guys who got
killed in car accident
and it just it just keeps on coming and
and the thing is we we're past the
amount of people that died on the
morning of 911 has been far surpassed by
illness deaths of rescue and Recovery
workers we're well over 3,000 now and I
think it's it's it's like a a couple of
week being
diagnosed with mostly
Cancers and
uh couple of month at least that are
dying and I and I know that you know
some people say well you know you can't
blame everything on 9 living they're
right you can't people die people get
sick but not every single freaking
person in your age bracket I mean I I I
know more of my buddies that are sick
almost that aren't and that's that's
frightening
but you know my old truck 114 I think
there's
now 16 guys out of the 28 that would add
up morning 911 that have cancer
but they call us the lucky truck because
every one of us with can is still here
there's other trucks who only had seven
or engines that have five but three of
them are dead or four of them are dead
and it's strange so you just say you
know what yes let me let me take that
gift and say I'm still here I'm still
lucky please don't let me and
complain about nonsense you know I you
know stopped in for coffee on the way
here doesn't make sense drinking coffee
on 100 degree day right but I do
and you know you see people they unravel
when uh when the Barista runs out of oat
milk or or or you know whatever it is
the specialty they use it's like okay
I'll just use half and half of milk it's
you're not is anybody going to get hurt
and it's funny I was flying back I was
in
Florida I was flying last night we
delayed five hours and this young girl
in front of me she very funny my
daughter's age and she was flipping out
over the
delay and I said yeah but it could be
worse she goes no no you're right you're
right I'm a medical student I see people
that are dying every day I
says thanks for healing I said cancer
survivor I love you guys and she we got
into this huge conversation and she says
you're right she goes we get so wrapped
up in and we don't realize
what's really
important and you know I always had a
love and a zest for life I I I I really
I'm not going to lie and say that
there's days that I'm not down maybe
depressed maybe you know pissed off
but I I I'm definitely a different
person I'm I'm gregarious I'm outgoing
I'm a little bit uh I'm a little
different I talk to everybody because I
just want people to know like someone
gives a about them and you know hey
if you're having a bad day I'll
listen but I really learned to listen in
the cancer
hospital I was first in a room with this
older African-American American
gentleman and he was in stage of throat
cancer and they they basically gave him
a couple days to live and uh he couldn't
talk
so he would be trying to let them know
like he needed something something and
and no one no one can understand him so
he waved at me when I first introduced
myself when I got in there and at that
time I wasn't hooked up to the drugs and
the IV and stuff I was still a little
mobile and uh
he waved at me to come over so you know
I said yeah sir you know I forget his
name God forgive me now but I said and
and he waved like come in so I put my
ear down by his mouth and he very raspy
like was trying to express and and I
could I could hear him so he would say
to me pray for me I don't have long and
I said all right sir and we
pray and he he called P me back the next
night and I check on him you know how
you doing sir are you good okay you know
try to give him a little
water but I noticed that none of the
nurses or the doctors would do that they
wouldn't they wouldn't put their ear
down they actually hear what he had to
say and I understand it maybe they just
hygienically or but I guess they didn't
think he could verbalize so the next
night he waves me in and he says to me
can you please call my sister she's in
North Carolina I need to let her know
that I'm
going and I said okay I said do they
know he says yes yes they have the
number I want her to know that this is
the time I'm
going so I went out to the nurses
station and I said you know Mr Jones is
is trying to contact his
sister to let her know he's about to
pass and the nurse goes well how the
hell do you know that I said cuz I
listened she goes what do you mean he
can't talk I said no I said if you put
your ear down to his mouth I said you
can understand what he's saying I said
could you do me a favor can you get me
the number and I'll call the sister
she's like okay so she gave me the
number I called North Carolina I
explained who I was I said you know good
evening ma'am I said my name is Nels I
said I'm I'm a New York City
firefighter I'm in a hospital next to
your brother oh yes yes I said how is he
how is he I said he's not really doing
so great as you know but he wants to
talk to you so I gave him the
phone and he had a little conversation
with her and then he said goodbye and he
said I love you I and I was trying to
you know make out what he was saying
whatever so he waved at me that he was
finished and he handed me the phone and
I hung it up and I went back down and he
said thank you and I said that's okay
sir I said you hanging there I said you
let me know also what had happened is
they had moved me to the room next door
so now I wasn't his roommate anymore and
that's what it was I would check in on
him so I said okay sir I'll come back
I'll come back later and I'll check on
you okay and he went okay thank you and
I went back to my
room and an hour later I heard the
beep and I heard him say cold blue and I
got
up and I went oh man I hope I hope it's
not and I looked to the next door down
and the light was
blinking and they just they didn't
really work them because he had to do
not resuscitate so I just went in and I
I touched his leg and I said a quick
prayer and
uh I'm just glad I
listened and you know I I I felt like I
was doing what I used to do and every
time I I went to a scene where someone
was killed
crushed the
burnt and there was no chance that
they going to have a
tomorrow I'd go off to the side when the
rest of the guys were done with whatever
we were
doing and I'd stop and I kneel down I
take off my fire
helmet and I touched the person's hand
or you know whatever was discernible
after their bad day injuries
Burns and I just pray and I
say God I don't know if they had faith I
don't know what they believed and I
don't know what they did in their life
but I just hope that you can have some
understanding and some mercy and let
wherever they're going be better than
this and it didn't matter who they were
they could be white
black brown purple I didn't give a
it was just it was another human being
you
know
and I felt I felt obligated because most
of the time they died
alone and I just thinking if their
spirit is fading away I want them to see
that someone
cared a
stranger cared enough to
say I hope it's going to be
better and what's really ripping my soul
out you know some people say I
I've I've been blessed and honored I was
was involved in a in a in a podcast for
the 20th
anniversary 911 we tried to just let
people know don't forget and it was it
was you know asking them to help tuns
the towers which buils homes for killed
and seriously seriously when did respond
as a
military
and I just I just took it as as such an
honor like to to to have that chance to
talk talk to people again and I
interviewed people some of them were
just such heartbreaking stories
connected to 9/11 some of them who lost
their loved one or some of them who
barely got out with their
life and it was just
like the common I guess denominator of
it all was they just want to feel like
someone cares and somebody will remember
and I think that's what's going on in
society is like we've become so jaded so
angry for what over
nonsense just you know I know you can't
go up to strangers CU you'll you'll get
hurt right I mean
especially sometimes in this city it's
almost like an open range mental Asylum
I mean it's sad it's just these people
who are truly mentally ill cannot get
help cannot get served with what they
need to make them
better but people out there in their
everyday life especially those who face
tragedy and you know we you know you
walk into somebody you don't know what
they're facing are they sick is their
spouse sick or just try to let them know
you care but I I remember the common
denominator would speaking with a lot of
these people is we were hoping for 912
to come back and
91201 although in the an of history is
one of the worst days ever because it
was the morning after of you know the
worst day in America but yet when you
look down the Westside Highway and you
looked at all the areas is in the
perimeter of of World Trade Center there
was people lined up with
posters and and signs and American flags
and they were hugging and they were
didn't matter like what the hell they
were where they came from just there
that was out the window and it was such
a nice time in this country it was like
we were
unified but then it was just like gone
away in like six months or nine months
it just we got back to the normal
fighting and bull crap and you know now
you can't have a differing opinion and
now you can't disagree with that guy
right you know it's just we've come to
the point we can't have conversations
anymore they're
confrontations and it's strange it's
like how are we ever going to learn
about each other if we can't
communicate and the forces that are out
there don't want us communicating they
want us
fighting I don't understand it and as a
divided country
how are we going to get through the next
911 because it's coming don't know when
Henry Miller knew it was coming he
didn't know when either but it's
coming the problem now is 22 years later
we are fractured we are a broken body of
a country how is that body going to
withstand the pain and the beating that
could come with an attack or a war or
another
whatever the hell just happened with Co
and how are we going to get through
that I don't know me personally I'm a
big fan of God family country bring it
back you don't necessarily have to go to
church but just just just have a faith
in
something but I'm sorry but if you
refute family and Country you're way
wrong because that's that's what built
this damn place and it's it's it's just
we're trying to we're trying trying to
refute it and Chip it away and just make
it go away but it's it's not there's
people
that they love this country so much you
know my my grandpa Nils he he left
Denmark he was a young young guy he left
home at 12 years old to be an apprentice
Baker and he was tormented by that
because he really never went back and he
joined the
Navy and he hopped on a ship and he came
to America with you know 30 bucks in his
pocket and he made it he made it he
worked worked his ass off and I remember
walking through Bay Ridge holding his
hand and he was incredible
grandfather but he was trying to make up
for being a horrible
father and now as a man and as a father
I totally understand it he was he had
demons he wasn't good to my dad and his
sister is my grandma he used to get
violently drunk and rage but his rage
stemmed
from his not being loved right he was
thrown out at 12 to work not that his
parents didn't love him but I guess
that's just what they
did but I realized he was trying to make
up for it and he would walk around Bay
Ridge and he didn't believe in Banks or
checks Gramps it had to be cash he just
didn't trust anybody so he'd walk to the
phone company we walk to the electric
company he walk you know to the bank if
there was anything there and then then
we'd go to the bar cuz he liked the bar
I'd sit and have you
know a shot glass of soda he used to
call it
schnaps but I just remember we go down
by the pier in Bay Ridge and he loved
the ships because he was a Navy man and
he would with binoculars he'd show me
the listings on the back of the ship
where they were going where they were
flagged out of what country and he used
to call every one of them the slow booat
to China and I was just but Gramps they
they don't all come from China and it
was just his little joke and I remember
one day he heard the starbangle bound he
stopped in his tracks and he put his
hand on his heart he's
crying Grant why are you sad and he said
I'm not I'm not sad there tears of joy I
love this country it's given me so much
and it's going to give you so
much and then I see people burning that
same
flag every single piece of human remains
that we found at that site at the world
fade Center didn't matter if it was a
finger or a leg or a
human or just a pile of
Flesh we put it in a
backboard and we draped an American flag
over
it and every responder and every
recovery
worker stand that attention and we line
all the way up the
ramp and as six people people processed
that human soul up that ramp we
stop and we
salute and we
cry cuz we didn't even know if it was
our friend it was just
someone and now I get really really
pissed off when I see athletes that are
making 10 1520 million a year right
you're getting paid to play a
game that I would have played for free
and I would go back to my firet truck
for
free if they would let me and you're
pissing on this country that's paying
you 20 million to throw around a
ball or sing a song or make a
movie how dare
you and I'm sorry I'll probably get hate
mail and comments I don't care how dare
you foul lip this country if it's so
bad I'll drive you to JFK I'll
buy you a ticket and I'll send you to J
to Beijing or St Petersburg Russia one
way try Ukraine try it out let me know
how it is ain't as good as this
place yeah it's not perfect right we we
made
mistakes I'm first generation
American I love this
country couple years back just down the
street I got attacked by
14s that were angry they were angry Ang
at me I never even seen him in my
life and thank God I got out of it and I
just thought to myself how the fre could
you be 18 years old in America and be so
pissed off and angry you got every
opportunity available to you you could
be the president if you want don't
matter no one is going to stop you
except for you and that's what my father
told me no one owes you crap anything
you want you have to work
for you can't look at these idiot
influencers and think you're going to
just you know you have millions of
dollars in sports cars and you know your
body full of plastic and it could stop
it's a fake digital world live in the
real world live in
reality try your best you'll make
it and that's just what hurts there
people just spend every day bashing this
great place there's people dying to get
here they die trying to cross this
border I guess it doesn't suck that bad
all right NS thank you so much for your
incredible talk thanks Mark it's my
pleasure I'm sorry I was long winded no
it's
interesting